look at that oh my god that's always a
good time they shot that for real
with physical models that's awesome this
is one of the most difficult shots
that we've ever broken down in this show
but do the pores stretch
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get three free months of
membership
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react we got niko
clinton myself here today
our friend john favreau has gifted us
with an awesome vfx shot to react to
i have never received more messages
about anything for visual effects
artistry act
than to react to the end of the show
luke skywalker is back in star wars but
not just any luke
young luke hold on to your mice
everybody i hope they're wired so you
don't lose them when they go flying
across the room when you react to this
episode
or if you're sitting on the toilet hang
onto those phones because you do not
want to drop them into the toilet it'd
be very bad
let's jump in oh boy
[Music]
you don't have to hold back plant you
can scream
all right all right all right i think it
looks pretty dang good you know what
haters be damned hold on is it going to
close up
a little close up he wants your
permission
i think it's pretty great dude honestly
i think it looks pretty dang good
but as with every other time anyone's
ever done cg faces
it's not 100 you can always tell that
it's not real
and even though it's like 99 good the
fact that you can tell
changes everything this is about the
boldest effect you could do
because everyone knows that mark hamill
is old
and he doesn't look like that anymore
after they're done with oh
they're gonna be like wait a second and
they're going to take a really close
look at it if it's off by a hair then
it's going to be one of the most
nerve-wracking things as like a visual
effects artist
shot like this because luke skywalker is
such an iconic character he is the face
of star wars
so what we do know about this scene so
far is that they had a different actor
playing as a stand-in for luke skywalker
he had
tracking dots over his face and his head
was replaced that's the only thing we
know everything else is speculation
mark hamill was not actually on screen
here at all he was just providing the
voice off camera
this is one of the most difficult shots
that we've ever broken down in this show
there's nothing about how they did it
online
so we have to draw entirely from our
knowledge of visual effects and the
visual effects being done here
are not your standard throw cg model and
somebody can call it a day
there's more than that going on nico
what makes you think there's more going
on to this than just the normal face
replace
one this is a tv show it's not a film to
go out and make a
3d model of a young luke skywalker
that's
high fidelity enough to be photo real is
something that's
more or less cost prohibitive and time
prohibited for a tv show
the other thing is it's the quality of
it a cg face
has certain things about the quality of
it that it's a little hard to pinpoint
but you know there's very accurate
lighting on a cg model
there's very specific movement there's
like there's like a hyper detail to cg
that kind of stands out you know if you
look at moff tarkin and how that face is
lit and how the skin texture kind of
moves and all stuff versus
luke here luke is very flat his
his face is not very animated even when
his mouth moves it's you know it's a
little bit like
and like the kind of the eyes just stare
off into the distance and the lighting
on his face too it's very generalized
and
arguably not quite matching the scene
it's not bad it looks kind of photoreal
but it's this weird
soft ambi directional light like look at
baby yoda there like the lighting on his
face like there's very distinct shadows
there's very distinct creases
there's none of that in luke skywalker
here so everything's telling me that
this is not a 3d model this is
at least involving some sort of ai face
thing going on
we're going to talk about this shot and
how we think is defect and once again
this is just speculation
we've talked about defects before but
just to touch upon it the computer is
basically
learning how to draw a face from looking
at pictures of a face
and you're going to feed it landmarks of
a new face like here's the eyes here's
the nose here's the mouth
and the computer is going to take how it
learned to draw a face and it's going to
draw those parts of the face
on these landmarks obviously we've done
some defects on this channel before
but i actually had the opportunity last
year to work with the south park team
helping to develop the deep voodoo
effects company that they started which
is an
ai based visual effects company that
mainly uh focused on deep fakes
last year so i was working with him and
it was just an intensive like
six months of just deep fake deep deep
deep pick and just getting into
technology and i had the opportunity to
see and work on
literally the best defects in the world
and you can go and see that right now
on the sassy justice youtube channel oh
the link in the description below
anyways long story short
i've gotten to see what the best defects
in the world look like in 2020
disney released a paper talking about
their own
deep fake method that they've been
working on that just so happens to
coincide about with the time
they'd be working on these shots for the
mandalorian if you look
at their deep fakes it's got that same
quality right it's the way it moves it's
a little bit of that stiffness it's the
lighting quality it's the
kind of eyes staring off into space not
having all the micro movements that eyes
should have
that's one of the challenges about deep
fakes is like it's getting expressions
and performance to come through the deep
fake
because no matter what when you apply a
defect just something that's going to
stiffen down and like
simplify the performance a little bit
because it can only pull from
expressions
that exist from the images of whatever
actor you're deep faking
nico yeah but do the pores stretch
they do your pores stretch wait do they
though can we actually tell
look if it's if it's a deep fake they
stretch
because any expression that would have
stretched pores is pulling from a
picture
where the pores are stretched pretty
crazy what's so special about this
though because we've been
talking about something you know
breaking it down to the nitty-gritty but
what's so
groundbreaking about this is that we're
reaching a point
where we can do full-on cg characters we
can bring luke skywalker back to life in
his younger form
for a tv show with a couple weeks of
work theoretically
this is unthinkable five years ago could
it be a little bit better
totally i totally think so now we've
been talking about deep fakes and how
we've done defects and all kind of stuff
let's try making luke skywalker this is
something i i wanted to do this for a
while once i've
learned how to do deep fix it's like man
i can bring these old characters back to
life that i love
that you can't film with anymore can we
do it and what would it look like
so we did that and it's a video that's
coming out
tomorrow so subscribe to corridor and
check it out
and tell us how we did it's a full-on
deep dive into the tech
and what you can do with it and the
question of can we make it as good
so you guys ready to see the most
intense
water simulation you've ever seen i've
seen a lot of water sims in my day niko
you've never seen one like this ever
seen like this all right
oh sick hold on to your spin suits here
we go
there's more shot that's very nice and
it's a really cool design
right here
dude that's pretty nice too
look at the like the way they slosh in
those like yeah exactly engines
this is that was so high level first
things first this shot right here
is insane it's almost it's so insane
that it just kind of looks normal
because that's how things look when
they're being pulled out of water that
is i think one of the most realistic
shots i've seen in this entire series
you can really feel the weight of the
water pressing down on the ship and when
the suction of the water is released
from the top of the ship you can feel
the ship actually
break free and it's such a nice feeling
when you're doing water simulations
you're basically doing a particle
simulation so
in cg they basically created a box and
they filled it with particles and each
one of these particles has a parameter
with how they're going to influence the
particles around them how much do they
stick how much are they not stick and
the way that all flows and works
together you can kind of like
smooth it out and you get water now the
thing is if you have too few particles
your water looks really globby and
chunky and you almost end up seeing the
actual particles
of course in real life water does kind
of turn into particles in the air but
they're very very tiny but if you look
at
all the ripples and all the waves and
all that detail
that means that the particles being used
for this water simulation are so tiny
and there's so much of it it's insane
it's insane the amount of processing
power needed to do
that shot is just incredible not to
mention how nicely it's rendered like
you see the ship
through the water like you'll notice how
the ship's blurrier the further away
from the surface it is and it takes on a
color the further away from the surface
it is these are all like really advanced
rendering and shading techniques also
the white caps yeah and the fun
because that that's like that's the
another level to it you're gonna have
foam
and they're doing a whole bunch of it
right here and it looks incredible
you also have a physics simulation with
a ship you know being pushed down by the
water as the water flows off of it it
changes the balance on the rope you have
a rope simulation which is basically a
fancy cloth simulation going on and you
have seaweed moving around and sloshing
around which is also a cloth stimulation
and so not only is the water doing
things but the water is affecting
other simulations at the same time and
having different physics systems
communicate with each other like that is
so incredibly hard to do you still don't
see
things in movies where like the smoke
from an explosion pushes like boxes over
because
something like a box would be simulated
in a different physics system than like
fire and smoke they still have
scientists trying to figure out how to
do that with artificial intelligence
right now
because it's so complicated and hard to
do and here they are doing it all in
front of you and it's so well done
you're just like oh that's pretty
another happy landing so if you like
episodes where we do deep dives into
certain shows and movies we did one
about lord of the rings last year
and we want to do one about harry potter
break down all the effects in the entire
harry potter
series leave a comment if you have
specific scenes from the harry potter
movies that you want to see
wait is that bill burr what is he doing
in star wars
this is actually a really heartwarming
episode
so clint yeah i also know you like
explosions
i like a good explosion are you ready
for some of the most intense
explosion simulations i've ever seen i'm
ready
are you i think so yeah i think so
yeah this shot
oh yeah oh that's always a good time
yeah i love it it's so beautiful that's
the extra spike i just i want
i want to watch that on luke forever so
basically what you're seeing are the tie
fighters like flying through and they
leave a very intense like vorticity
trail behind them of just churned up air
and also a pressure differential as they
go through it it's lower pressure and
that causes
air around it to rush in and it's not
just going to like suck in like a vacuum
it's actually going to go through
currents
and that you can actually see that in
real footage anytime there's like an
explosion or something and like an
airplane flies by it kind of like causes
these uh ripple ways there's an actual
shot in another film
where they do this with actual planes
oh yes oh my god
look at that beautiful shot perfectly
framed
perfectly timed pyrotechnics that looks
exactly like the shot from the
mandalorian they had to have used this
for reference because this is
perfect reference just the actual like
fluid mechanics like i literally just
yelled at my tv and rewound and just
watched it over and over
the funny thing too is like these
explosions the tie fighter shots all
blowing up in those big fireballs
you know a real concussive explosion
doesn't look like that you know
custom explosions mostly just dust and
smoke with a flash and in movies those
kind of fireballs that you see that's
gasoline it's basically gasoline being
thrown into the air with another
explosive of some type and that gasoline
you know being vaporized ignites and
turns into a big fireball
you know whether or not lasers would
turn into giant gasoline explosions
probably not realistic but giant laser
hit the ground i don't think there'd be
any explosion there'd be a
big steaming hole of melted sand
also like what are those laser bolts if
it was an actual laser gonna be like
yeah but it's the kind of pretty
explosion that we've all
grown to love in hollywood films and
they just they nail the look for sure
here it's really really satisfying
so the ship you're seeing right now they
shot that for real
that's awesome they actually
legitimately do a hardcore vfx throwback
to the 70s with physical models and it
looks legit
like it's from the originals the fun
trick with with those practical ship
models
is that the ship's actually not moving
at all it's just the camera that's
moving
yeah and once you put on a static
background it looks like the camera's
standing still now
and the ship is moving which is how they
had to do it back in the day because the
models are so big and so heavy that you
can't
be swinging those around john null the
guy who invented photoshop and is like
president of ilm
this is like his pet project is like
this isn't too important to the overall
scope of the show
it's to be completely honest unnecessary
like
they spent so much more time and money
probably just to be able to do these
shots physically for real
than to do a cg and the cg models i mean
this is island we're talking about it
would have looked
just as good they could have made it
look handcrafted like this if they
wanted to
and it would have looked exactly the
same but i do think it does have a lot
of value
for like how we feel about the show
because it kind of gives it a sense of
authenticity
not just in terms of what you're seeing
but the craftsmanship involved in the
project
as a whole i feel like it's a good
reminder that like there's still passion
and craft in this
yeah it's not all for money yeah dude
the people working on the show must be
having the best time of their lives
because
they're able to do this this way which
is like
what they probably grew up being like
this is the best thing ever i'd love to
do that and now they had the opportunity
to do so because
the show's doing well it's funded like
it has a good budget
and it's like the top people in the
industry working on this stuff
that's your great great great
grandfather
if you are concerned at all with your
privacy on the internet or you want to
see what the internet is like in
different regions of the world consider
using a vpn in this case
expressvpn expressvpn is a service that
allows you
to protect your internet traffic and
relocate it to different parts of the
world
expressvpn offers some of the fastest
connection speeds you can possibly have
through a vpn and has world-class
customer support
expressvpn can do things like allow you
to access movie libraries that are only
available in other countries for example
out in the uk all of the studio ghibli
films are available on netflix so you
can use expressvpn
to unlock that library for you to view
at your home in america
pretty cool stuff in fact i discovered
that there's nine different countries
that have their own version of the
office
i mean we've seen the american one here
and there's the original british one
and i guess there's just like seven more
offices now the office is no longer
available
on netflix in the united states but it
is available in canada so i can just go
over to canada here quote netflix
and boom now i'm watching the office
again why would they take the office off
at netflix i don't know
if you want to experience the internet
without borders just like it's intended
to be
consider signing up for expressvpn if
you would like three free months of
membership you can go to expressvpn.com
corridor crew or click on the link in
the description below
thanks
[Music]
if you thought this whole conversation
was interesting and you want to actually
see more subscribe to the corridor crew
channel
we are trying to one-up star wars to see
if we can do a better young luke
skywalker and that video comes out
tomorrow so if you don't want to miss it
please consider subscribing
to corridor crew it's really cool to
take a look at this luke skywalker shot
it was really cool to also mention the
work i did with the deep voodoo effects
team because that's something i worked
on for a ton of last year and i had to
keep secret
and uh you know finally the cat's out of
the bag so
yeah deep fix crazy stuff deep learning
crazy stuff
how far away are we from just every
single actor you can just cast
like c-list actors and just
deep-fake on a-list faces like how far
away are we from like that being a
pretty reasonable thing
five years that's every five years you
know what let's continue this
on the corridor podcast that's right
everybody we have a corridor podcast
youtube.comcast
and i think we should delve into this in
the very next episode
at some point we're gonna have a stamp
of pride
that this was made by humans oh man this
script was written by a person